alors on va rien dire mais je sais que
hier soir vous avez rencontré mike
pietrus jury concis s'est passé et on a
droit de faire des trucs non bien
j'avais non mais c'est entre nous je
dois dire que c'est très sympa qu'on a
passé un moment formidable que les
rencontres se sont passées comme on
l'espérait c'est à dire la belle soirée
et vous vous avez passé rebelles soient
bien pour être membre du jury se prépare
et vous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
comment ça s'est passé toute cette
préparation pour devenir membre du jury
à cannes
honnêtement pour répondre sincèrement je
crois pas que je me sois réellement
préparé je viens comme invitée à cannes
comme si je n'avais steve alliés mais
qui a le privilège de pouvoir discuter
des plans secrets contre nous
très belle équipe d'ailleurs c'est un
plaisir ça des fois qu'on peut vous
parlez donc 24 films qui arrivent à
ostrava les deux films et demi trois
films par jour ça valait la sermat
est ce qu'on a assez dormi on s'est bien
préparés physiquement je sais pas mais
c'est un marathon est bon dans la gamme
deux jours après deux ans en cinéma l'a
carrément on va pouvoir recharger tout
ce qu'on a perdu depuis deux ans
d'accord merci beaucoup merci infiniment
très bon festival il peut paraître plus
[Musique]